aber 0,0 wirklich 0,0
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute die
leckerste vegane Schokotorte ich selbst
ernähre mich jetzt nicht vegan lege aber
immer mal wieder so ein veganen Tag bzw
eine vegane Mahlzeit ein oder mag es
auch einfach mal euch vegane Rezepte zu
zeigen die wirklich schmecken denn ich
finde das Problem ist immer weil vegane
Rezepten dass sie doof gesagt genau wenn
es egal ist mir so schmecken und nicht
diese Abstriche machen und haben sie ist
so ein bisschen du bist ja nicht Anti
vegan sondern du machst das vegan ne
also irgendwie bist du so richtig doch
anziehen
[Gelächter]
nein also ich muss sagen du bist immer
so wenn was veganes ist oder was draußen
warum ich finde so veganes Essen es muss
schon gut schmecken aber sonst lohnt
sich das nicht genau ich finde sogar
vegane kochen ist super easy aber backen
ist immer so ein bisschen
mehr schmeckt nicht genau und deswegen
ja also würde ich jetzt nicht ich glaube
schon es gibt wirklich sehr leckere
vegane Rezepte aber
gerade im Backbereich finde ich
man macht halt extreme Abstriche ich
habe letztens den leckersten vegan
Cheesecake gemacht blende ich euch gerne
ein äh das ist auf dem Kopf und keine
online gegangen und da habe ich auch
mein Anrufer es muss richtig geil
schmecken sonst werde ich es nicht
abgeben bzw so hochladen und deswegen
gibt's heute eine leckere vegane
Schokotorte so viel gequatscht mit zeige
ich euch aber mal wie das ganze
funktioniert ich schreibe euch alle ganz
genau
Mengenangabe und in die
Videobeschreibung und ich mache jetzt
ein Oreo Boden denn Oreos sind auch
vegan und dafür ähm male ich Oreo Kekse
fein und werde gleich noch vegane Butter
in der Mikrowelle zerlassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so jetzt habe ich hier meinen Tortenring
mit 20 cm Durchmesser ihr könnt auch
eine Springform nehmen und da gebe ich
jetzt den Oreo Boden rein ich habe hier
mein Lochblech mit einem Backpapier
unten drunter Ofen habe ich übrigens
schon vorgeheizt weil das ein sehr
schnelles Rezept ist und ähm ich rühre
gleich auch alles zusammen ich muss auch
nicht meine Küchenmaschine das ist ganz
ganz einfach ich drücke jetzt hier nur
einmal den Oreo Boden schön flach an und
gib den dann bis zur Weiterverarbeitung
in den Kühlschrank müsst ihr aber auch
nicht wenn ihr da keinen Platz habt ich
mag es einfach nur dass es noch mal
schön kalt ist und sitzt bevor es
gebacken wird aber es ist überhaupt kein
Muss
[Musik]
so und jetzt kommt ein richtig leckerer
und saftiger Veganer schokobohnen merkt
euch das Rezept gerne einfach so als
Basic weil das ist sehr einfach es ist
auch es gibt keine exotischen Zutaten
ich habe jetzt hier einfach Mehl in
meine Schüssel gegeben da kommt jetzt
Zucker mit rein und Backpulver dann habe
ich hier außerdem noch Backkakao für den
schokoanteil so und was auch nicht
fehlen darf ist gleich Vanilleextrakt
einfach für den Geschmack das ist ja
auch vegan verlinke ich euch gerne in
die Infobox und da kommen dann einfach
nur entweder Sonnenblumen oder Rapsöl
mit dazu und Apfelmus und Apfelmus sorgt
dann für die Bindung und er setzt dann
quasi das Ei und das ganze wird einfach
nur mit dem Schneebesen zusammengerührt
und so was ich auch noch vergessen habe
ich denke schon irgendwie eine
Flüssigkeit ähm Mineralwasser mit
Kohlensäure das kommt nämlich auch noch
gleich dazu und dann habt ihr nämlich so
einen richtig schönen Teig und der kommt
dann auf den Oreo Boden
[Musik]
so der Kuchen ist jetzt aus dem Ofen bei
180°c
gelassen euch das zu zeigen dass hier
ein bisschen von der Butter Austritt
dürft euch nicht irritieren lassen ich
nehme jetzt ein cakeboard und nimm den
runter der ist jetzt komplett abgekühlt
es geht doch echt einfach und da kommt
jetzt noch unser Schokoguss drauf und
dafür brauchen wir drei ganz simple
Zutaten ich habe jetzt
Zartbitterkuvertüre die ist ja meistens
schon vegan dann habe ich hier braunen
Zucker ihr könnt auch ganz normalen
weißen Haushaltszucker nehmen aber der
hat einfach so ein karamelligen
Geschmack und statt der Sahne die ich
jetzt eigentlich für so eine Ganache
bräuchte nehme ich einfach Kokosmilch
nimmt da bitte die voll fett Variante
also nichts fettreduziertes und rührt
bitte die Kokosmilch in der Dose um mal
oben sind immer diese Feststoffe und
dann ist das einmal unten das müsst ihr
kräftig umrühren und dann eben die
Grammzahl abwägen
[Musik]
für die Ganache einfach alle Zutaten in
den Topf geben bei mittlerer Stufe
langsam erwärmen wenn ihr das alles zu
heiß haben solltet dann wird es super
flüssig und dann müsst ihr das ganze 15
Minuten auskühlen lassen die Konsistenz
sollte dann etwa so sein die wird aber
auch fester das passiert alles nach der
Kühlzeit ich gebe jetzt erstmal mein
Kuchen runter vom cakeboard gehe auf die
Tortenplatte wenn ihr kein Platz auf dem
Kühlschrank dann könnt ihr das einfach
auf dem cakeboard lassen manche haben
keinen Platz jetzt so eine ganze
tortenplätze in den Kühlschrank zu
stellen aber ich habe mir Platz
geschaffen ich gebe jetzt einmal die
Schokoganache oben drüber und dann wird
sie je nachdem wie kalt euer Kühlschrank
eingestellt ist eventuell nach
anderthalb Stunden schon super Fest
manche brauchen vielleicht ähm
zweieinhalb bis drei Stunden schaut
einfach dass die Oberfläche schön fest
ist dann könnt ihr nämlich den
Tortenring entfernen und dann dekoriere
ich persönlich nur noch mit so einem
Oreo crumbles hat mir einfach ein
bisschen klein geschnittenes wildes und
miniorius habe ich noch irgendwo in den
Tiefe meines Schranks gefunden die gebe
ich da auch noch mit drauf und dann
machen wir den test test und da bin ich
richtig gespannt auf haben sie das
kritische Meinung
[Musik]
er ist kaputt hier ist egal
aufnehmen müssen
einfach wunderbar so ich probiere jetzt
an ist das egal
[Musik]
ich bin eine Sache extrem krass gerade
weißt du was ich meine Schokolade
aber 0,0 wirklich
0,0 Apfel übrigens nicht raus weil ich
wollte gerade sagen
einfach voll Schokolade Geschmack ist
dadurch den Boden
schmeckt aber für einen Moment hätte ich
gedacht das ist vegan ist aber nur
vielleicht auch ein Unterbewusstsein
weil das mitbekommen ja das stimmt ja
wenn es so wäre könnte ich das auch zu
reden das wäre kein Problem nach und
schmeckt sie dann raus aber es schmeckt
so lecker so Schokolade
mein Kokosmilch statt Sahne
Apfelmus drin
[Musik]
du bist jetzt kein Veganer Bäcker oder
Konditor oder Koch oder sowas aber du
kannst krass backen ohne Spaß
zeigen und der Veganismus richtig gut
geworden
für Rosalinde
du vegan für Rosalinde aber ich bin
vegan für
also ich wünsche euch viel Spaß beim
Nachbacken wir uns auch bei mir ach so
schreibt mir doch gerne mal in die
Kommentare ob ihr jetzt ich weiß ich
habe jetzt nicht nur vegane in die
Community aber möchtet ihr wieder mal
einen veganes Rezept oder nicht
das Problem ist es so unverschämt weil
ich eben vorne nicht kenne dann mache
ich das erst wenn ich recherchiert habe
wie sie heißt ich weiß nur dass die
Ärztin ist also
einmal tschüss
[Musik]